guys it's so great to see you all at
Leonard Cohen comic-con today tell me
who you are hi i'm freddie and injustice
dinero's I'm el and I'm dressed as
tanaris i'm gerry and I'm just as De
Niro stew I'm collective you are denair
I again now what made you want to cover
scenarios today and the inspiration to
be tenaris is because I get to have
dragons and set people on fire which is
a pretty good life goal I think and
you've got a little dragon here we show
it for the camera throw gone he's one of
her three dragons and he's her favorite
how about you as well you got your
dragon egg there is what haven't you
yeah I just love to notice I love her
character l apparently the books and I
love her in the TV shows now what is it
about teen Targaryen that rocks so much
I think it's just the strength of the
characters they're really strong the
very interior and I just got beautiful
like physique and she's got one of the
best claims to the throne out of all of
them because her family have actually
held it pretty recently so in terms of
Game of Thrones she can ride in with
dragons and she's got a much better
chance than what else I think now what
would you like to see happen in season 4
oh there's a lot that would be good to
happen but the best thing to happen i
think someone take down Joffrey I don't
matter how but as long as he's down
that's good for me how would you like to
see it happen ooh poison maybe there's a
lot of people around him who could
poison him very easily and that would be
a slow lingering death so I'd like that
I think a nasty death for a nasty
definitely what do you think about
Joffrey as well yeah I mean I don't
think anyone likes draw free like I feel
really sorry for the actor but everybody
hates her but um yeah I think Joffrey's
one I just want two hours to get there I
want her to get there because she's just
over the sea on our own I like I want
her to get there and I want ya Joffrey
to fall basically I think it's
absolutely foul is that the one of the
worst character come across in a TV show
and it's right behind your shoulder
there as well it's very creepy but now I
really like if dinero's actually took
Joffrey down I'd really like that
justice the nose of my favorite curtain
drops my worst ones and I think she
should be the one to finish everything
now if you had your own dragons as Danny
of course tis on the show what would you
be doing with them world domination
you've got dragons you've got massive
things the size of several buses which
can swoop down from on high can pick
people off a at a single bite we're all
termination obviously and we do you
would you be evil like Joffrey with your
world domination would you be benevolent
like De Niro benevolent dictator I think
I would not like to be liked an heiress
and try and like maybe help people and
maybe take down the government no but
not because I need they don't agree with
the government yeah now guys what do you
think of emilia clarke in the royalton
errors she's really good fun and she
brings a very kind of quiet style to it
as well so that she's got an awful lot
of power but she doesn't she doesn't
show it off the way a lot of the other
lead characters do because a lot of the
others they they show off they yell they
have tantrums she tends to keep things
very very quiet
because she doesn't need to yell because
she's got the 8,000 unsullied she's got
the Dragons she's got a lot of power
behind her and I like I like the way she
brings that to it that quietness what do
you think she would be like as the
leader of Westeros on that Iron Throne I
think should be a really nice leader and
she's very reserved so she went like she
said that she would be like all shouting
angry she be very benevolent and she'd
have people would love her I think even
though people at the moment they don't
like but I think that everyone she could
bring everyone to her side and they'd
all love her rather than be like oh we
just want a new king and on new queen so
yeah I can I'd like her how about years
old do you think she'd rock on that
throne definitely I think she's as the
other sadist she's a different type of
power she's very like soft and gentle
because she doesn't need to be so
aggressive I think that's why people
like hell we see in the show everyone
dies that's not even a spoiler everyone
dies so I think like because she's not
going around chopping people's heads off
I think that's that's something that
people would admire
you